- All of these shots just
remind me of breakups.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- Like American food and
everything else from America,
it's just something turned way up.
- I feel nervous.
I'm also hung over, so
this is like my worst
nightmare right now.
- Let's get really drunk.
- Yeah.
- Let's do this.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- The Fireball, I've heard
a lot about this from
our good friend Eugene back in L.A.
- It smells like (mumbles).
- Yeah, big red.
- It sounds extreme.
- Whiskey's at my alley,
I can do Whiskey. Cheers.
- Be up your alley in a second.
- That's pure sex there.
- You can't really taste
the Whiskey at all.
- The top of the tongue all
the way down to the anus.
It kinda like just,
invigorates the whole body.
- If Donna King ever
started selling alcohol,
it should be this.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Having a cinnamon doughnut,
and a Fireball shot...
- Parents would love it.
- Yeah, actually I want one right now.
- Yeah, let's do it.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- So this is called a Blow Job,
or as in Australia, we call it, a gubby.
(laughs)
- I can't comfortably shot this without,
without it getting all over my face.
- Like a blow job.
- It looks and sounds
like the kind of shot
you'd get at a strip club.
- Do I open my mouth and
pull the whole thing?
- Like, Ah.
- I (mumbles) cream,
I know I shouldn't say that.
- It's just all over my mouth.
A courtesy tap would have been nice.
- No that shitty.
- Almost like a Tiramisu.
- How do you order that at a pub?
- Mmmh.
- Pretty much like having an Irish coffee.
- I see myself having a Blow Job at home,
at work, maybe at church.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- [Voiceover] This is a Pickleback.
- It looks like urine, like,
while you're drinking, and then
like while you're hydrated.
- Fuck that.
- Bit of a cheeseburger after taste.
- It's like Ronald McDonald
(bleep) in my mouth.
- Possibly the worse shot I've ever had.
- I wanna speak to the person
who first came up with this.
And just, why?
(mid tempo guitar music)
- [Voiceover] This is Alabama Slammer.
Got to say, catchy name.
- When you get really close,
it smells like Dr. Pepper.
- You know when you're in a club
and all the alcohol is kinda
fuzzed together on the floor?
That's what this smells like.
- That's a (mumbles) shot.
- I feel like it's something
you would get at like,
when you go out to a dinner party
with like your mom and dad,
and someone old like, pulls
out a really cheesy shot.
- Not as strong as what it smelled like.
- For me, it tastes like
medicine so much that like,
I'm associating with sitting in like
a Doctor's waiting room.
- No it's healthy.
Medicine is good for you.
- Another.
- Well done Alabama.
- Yeah.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- So this is a Lemon Drop,
and it sounds like
something your grandmother
would give you.
- This looks good.
This looks like a Lemon
Rusky has been compressed
and put into a shot.
- It tastes like a lemon Smirnoff,
but being left out in the
sun for about four hours.
- Super sweet.
- I feel refreshed.
I feel like I just like, licked the bottom
of like a Pinol clean bottom.
- How many of these can you have,
before you get diabetes?
- Wow, that is cordial.
Like not straight cordial,
what a down cordial?
- I think if you served
that with like crushed ice,
I'd be way into that.
- I'm for team Lemon Drop.
- After today, popular shots from America,
are everything we thought they would be.
- I'm quite intoxicated.
That's a good thing.
- I think Australia really
needs to raise our shot game.
- I think the Americans
have a bit of work to do.
- These shots do make America great again.
- And I love you America.
You do food and drink like
no one else in the world.
Please let me live there.
- I appreciate your effort, America.
- Please let me live there (mumbles)